this is a super cute puppy
he has a pink tongue black fur and very
friendly personality
we know that when this puppy grows up he
will have a healthy weight of about 70
pounds he will love to play fetch and
enjoy snuggles with his human family
we know this because these traits are
typical of his breed labradors
but where do these traits come from in
this video we're gonna find out
but first let's start at the beginning
what exactly are traits
traits are specific observable
characteristics
they can be physical like our puppies
eye color
they can be behavioral such as a dog
being more or less aggressive towards
strangers
or they can be health related such as a
dog's risk of developing a certain
disease
traits are passed from parents to
offspring this is why our puppy looks so
similar to his parents who were also
labradors
but how does this occur
well
traits are passed on from one generation
to the next through the inheritance of
genes are pieces of hereditary material
that are passed from parents to
offspring
genes are found inside of an organism's
cells as part of structures called
chromosomes in multicellular organisms
chromosomes are found inside the cell
nucleus
chromosomes are often shown as x-shaped
structures like this one
each chromosome is a structure that
contains one long molecule of dna
which stands for
deoxyribonucleic acid all right sing it
with me
deoxyribonucleic acid
or dna for short
here's a model showing a small stretch
of a dna molecule you can see that it's
made up of lots of different atoms
represented by these colored balls
the dna molecule in a chromosome is like
this but much much longer
a chromosomes dna molecule is coiled up
in an organized way
this diagram shows what the dna would
look like if it were stretched out
this allows us to see where a
chromosomes genes are located
genes are specific stretches of a
chromosome's dna molecule
each chromosome's dna can contain
hundreds or even thousands of genes
and in multicellular organisms each cell
contains multiple chromosomes
it's the collection of genes and
chromosomes that contain the information
about all of an organism's inherited
traits
like our puppy here his chromosomes
contain thousands of jeans to help him
determine his coat color eye color and
all the other traits he inherited from
his parents
so our puppy must have one or more genes
that cause him to have black fur
if he had been born with different
versions of the fur collar jeans he may
have had yellow or brown fur
heck maybe one day someone will figure
out how to change a puppy's dna so that
he has pink fur and who knows maybe
you'll be the geneticist to make it
happen that's it for today thanks for
watching and i hope to be seeing some
pink puppies one day soon